the JavaScript unconference is a
conference by the community for
community they proposed talks the people
vote of the talks and then the most
famous topics will be held so this is
the third year we are running this
conference and for the first time we get
more than 400 participants we got 30
trucks and the priority of course is
pretty great we got everything from
protocols to CSS and everything
JavaScript related
you
Oh what I like about the JavaScript
community mostly the people already open
line it and yeah I can just find that
every conferences great people to talk I
guess I really like the the fact that we
have these these long breaks in between
that it's not sort of like go go go from
one talk to another we have a couple
talks and then lunch a couple talks and
thinks we can be people talk with them
find out what everybody is doing here I
like the whole package I would stay and
I like the style of the conference that
you don't know what will happen to look
around it's just basically a bunch of
nice people helping each other and
sharing knowledge it was interesting
that you get a surprise you're coming
here then some people randomly say hey I
want to speak about this and then we all
both about what we want to say so I like
the spontaneous way of this the
community is growing it's so interesting
and conferences like this is a great
place to learn new things and I don't
see the distinction between the people
who have the knowledge and the people
who don't so everyone knows something
and just shared and so it's great all
the connections that you can do in the
just in the toes but also outside you
know and the main room and meet the
people talk about their feelings know a
little bit what they are doing you know
and it's very informal everything and
that's what makes gsm conference maybe
the best conference in europe
I